I'd like to hear your thoughts on people entering the military in their thirties
I'm sure you saw it.
How did they fare?
I don't remember.
Military at an older age is fine.
You got maturity,
you've got experience,
you've got intelligence and so that's good.
You're going to bring a lot to the table.
However,
you also have maturity,
experience and intelligence,
so the only downfall of it is you got to do some dumb stuff when you're in the
military and and,
and if you're older and you see how dumb some of the stuff that you're doing is,
it's going to be harder for you to do it.
You're going to have a little bit of a negative attitude on if you allow
yourself,
it'd be easy to,
I should say that if you allow yourself,
it'd be easy to develop a negative attitude about that stuff.
I joined when I was 18 years old.
I didn't care.
You want me to do whatever you want me to do?
I'll do it.
I didn't see the stupidity and a lot of the stuff.
And so I think that's the only drawback because you'll just be looking at some
of the stuff that you do in the military thinking,
oh,
this is much more efficient way to do this.
And if you let that get to you,
it's going to be problematic.
So going there with an open mind,
do the crap,
the tedious and kind of mindless stuff that you got to do and push through that.
And then you'll get to a position of leadership and you can do your best to
mitigate that and take care of other soldiers,
sailors,
airmen,
and Marines while you're out there serving the country.
So yeah,
it's awesome.
It's great.
You'll,
you'll be a big benefit.
Do you think that,
that even that,
um,
how you're saying like,
okay,
you'll,
you kind of look at things in more of an adult way kind of thing where it's
like,
well,
there's more physically to do something.
Like,
do you think that that mindset would kind of keep you from,
uh,
you know,
being more cohesive to with us if you allow it to,
it definitely will.
If you,
if you,
that's why I said you have to allow,
if you just go look,
this is,
this is the way it is right now.
I'm a [inaudible] in the military.
They're telling me to do this thing.
It doesn't make any sense right now.
I'm going to do it to the best of my ability and move forward.
If you say,
Oh this is stupid and you spread the negativity of the other guys,
but why are we doing this?
Students,
yeah,
it's going to be problematic to go in there and have a good attitude.
You can promote really quickly if you're squared away like that,
you know,
so you got a good opportunity ahead of you.
It's,
I think it's totally good to go.
What about even like socially,
you know like kind of like,
oh
these kids are 18 you've been out in the world,
you've had a job,
you probably have a house,
you might have kids.
These kids are,
I was out of high school,
like,
you know what I mean?
It's,
you're not there yet.
You're,
and you think about what,
you know,
when you're that age compared to what,
when you're,
when you're 30,
you know,
my big thing is I tell my kids all the time,
or like my oldest daughter who's in college and whatnot,
and I'm always like,
when I was your age,
I was in my first seal platoon.
You know,
like,
you just can't even compete with what I was doing with the responsibility that I
had when I was 18 years old.
You know,
all that stuff.
Um,
but,
but the truth is,
when you're 18 you're not as mature as you are when you're 30 so yeah,
there'll be a social disconnect.
Like I went to college when I was,
I think I was 28 or 29 or 30.
And so,
yeah,
I was around kids that were 18,
19 years old.
And I very quickly that,
you know,
you'd meet some mature kids,
but a lot of kids were just,
they were just young,
you know.
I mean there's not a big difference between 18 and 15 for some people.
Right?
Yeah,
it's true.
You think about what you were doing,
you were 15 years old,
16 years old.
Like I joined the military.
So luckily I had some kind of structure imposed upon me.
Yeah.
But you think about the kind of stuff that you can do when you're 18 years old,
people do dumb,
dumb,
dumb stuff.
Yeah.
You,
you,
you look back and you're happy that you made it.
Yeah.
Yes.
Cause you do dumb stuff.
Dumb stuff.
No,
we're talking about wasting your time on youtube videos.
Go waste your time on Youtube.
Like just put in penal teenagers doing dumb stuff and you'll,
you'll say,
wow,
50% of the stuff that you see,
you'll recognize like,
oh yeah,
I remember that.
So yeah,
don't do dumb stuff.
And as a 30 year old in the military you can help give some of that guidance to
people.
So I think it's cool.
Go for it man.
And kind of vice versa.
Right?
Cause like if you're the 18 year old 19 year old guy,
there's like you know a hundred well however many other 1819 year old guys,
you guys are cruising then here comes this 30 year old.
Yeah.
You know,
all levelheaded brought,
I can't relate to this guy,
this guy.
Kind of weird that.
The other thing is when you're 18 you don't even know how much those 30 year
olds,
you just think you have there that you actually think you know more than you're
looking at them like they're idiots.
Why would you not,
you know,
swing off this rope and see if you can get through the window on the third
floor.
Why would you not do that and what exactly.
Yeah,
so that's something I would be,
I would brace yourself for that too.
Remember the perspective of an 18 year old and they're not looking at you going,
gosh,
I'd really like to learn a lot.
They're looking at you like,
I can't believe you're joined the military.
What's wrong with you?
Yeah.
Oh Man.
There is.
There were guys who actually,
they came from the military and still eligible for,
for football in college and one of those $26,000 27 and let's think,
let's face it,
26 27 that's Yo,
that's your physically like you're solid still.
And we looked at them,
it's like,
man,
these are like,
these are old school guys.
One careful with my own practice.
Literally it was like,
I felt like that for one of the guys anyway.
And then you go to class,
right?
And you get these people who,
you know,
they don't go to college right after high school.
They go,
you know,
later on when,
in my opinion,
when most of us should go,
when you know why you're going.
And so this one lady was in my class,
she was maybe 35 maybe 36 whatever.
[inaudible] look at you with disgust all day long.
No,
she didn't look at me at all.
She just freaking donor on program.
Yeah.
Like I was no factor in her life.
She was doing,
yeah.
Literally the correct way to do it.
She sat up front,
they go weird.
Oh,
you know,
and she's asking questions protocol,
literally.
And that's really the way to go when you think about it.
You don't even have to think about that's the way to go.
But nonetheless,
she's like this,
but she's obviously 30 something years old and it just didn't compute to me.
You know?
Like I was like,
I just didn't get it.
[inaudible] important thing.
Well,
not most,
but that's a really key part of this conversation is when you're eight,
imagine as a 30 year old.
When you're looking at that 18 year old,
they don't see it.
I don't understand anything.
Certain things.
So check.
No Sir,
we don't want 18.